a foil mower is one of the most
versatile tools you can own it's one of
my favorites and one of the most popular
items that we sell it can replace a
finished Mower and a brush hog save you
money overall save you storage space but
that's just the tip of the iceberg the
unique design of a Flail Mower allows
you to finely cut your grass you can
maintain your lawn on a regular basis
but then you can head right out to your
Fields mow your Trails mow your field
all that brush all without making any
modifications to the tool one of the
very unique things about a Flail Mower
is the ability to offset to the side so
you can get into ditches around ponds
underneath trees along fence rows so you
can do all the things that brush Hogs
and finish mowers can do and then some
and I appreciate the compact nature of
the Flail Mower sitting so much closer
to your machine which is beneficial
whether you're on your lawn in the woods
or in the field depending on the series
you'll have the ability to manually or
hydraulically offset some of our fancier
models even offer the ability to tilt we
ship flail mowers all around the country
every day of the week get more
information at goodworks tractors.com